you're a new mama now so that's exciting
i am just in heaven smelling baby i mean
he's about to turn one so i'm like
slowly i know
there he is
a little gus
yeah he's almost one so i'm kind of like
migrating out of baby dumb into toddler
dumb yeah
it's wild it's it's just gonna get more
wild
with a five and seven year old um no but
you named him gus but it's august right
august so was there some something about
the month of august is that why you
august is when we found out that we were
having a boy
and um yeah it's also the month that my
husband was born so we just and we love
the name gus
yeah yeah because my husband's last name
is goldsmith and i like being an
alliterative name mandy moore and we
wanted to have a gigi yeah so
right yeah my kids are like that i like
alliteration yeah fun yeah so it's great
for monogramming yes
it's also nice for that um no but what's
the hardest part you think that you
didn't see coming like being a mama
and there's probably a lot yeah i mean i
don't even know where to begin all of it
it is every cliche in the book right for
those parents out there like life went
from sepia to technicolor like that i
mean it's just the most overwhelming
yeah all consuming love and it's funny
because i've been playing a mom on a
television show for six years and i'm
like wait can we go back to the
beginning now because i know what it's
like to be a mom i'm faking it
i am so method right now
[Laughter]
um was that hard though to play a mom
like not being a mom because i did hear
milo out of you a bit whenever he was
here because he said i had to teach her
how to do her first diaper like change
and you didn't know what to do did you
have a kid i yeah and i just my husband
and i neither of us really had any
experience with babies with me neither
before i had one so i just remember
having to lean on milo so hard
especially in the beginning of the show
which milo doesn't have children he
doesn't have children but he has nieces
and nephews i have nieces and nephews
and i still had never changed a diaper
before my children milo's just missing
that's your baby's butt
take care of your own i was like i
didn't make anybody do much showing me
how to swaddle how to change diapers
he's so good at that it was incredible
and even cut this was like the first
season and then i remember right before
i gave birth to gus last year same thing
it was like we were shooting a scene
where we had to like change and i'm like
i'm about to do this in real life and i
have no idea what i'm doing your
character on this show has three kids so
you were also one of three right i was
two oh were you middle i'm middle i'm
last born oh yeah but you were the only
girl i yes so that's different are you
no two girls but we were like seven
years apart seven and a half years apart
so yeah yeah yeah
is that hard growing up with two boys no
i mean i feel like i was super i had two
super protective
brothers on either side because it's
like the show in in a weird way it sort
of like echoes the show my brother used
to pin me down and do that spit thing
and suck it back up i'm gonna have
different childhoods
so that's kind of cool though how the
show was yeah yeah it's kind of like
echoes of my childhood but um but yeah i
get to live it out as their mother and
i'm the youngest one in the cast it's
all very strange
says have you ever actually come home
with the like older rebecca stuff on and
your baby be like who are you no but
he's come to visit me on set he's been
hanging out with me since he was a month
old on set and it is slightly confusing
although i argue i have to give him some
reason to go to therapy later so but
yeah he's kind of like i think he hears
my voice and he smells me so he knows
it's me but like you know i have a wig
on on top of that and all this like
prosthetic makeup yeah he was my little
makeup artist right but at his face
you made such a beautiful baby
oh my gosh he is confused but you know
he's got to get used to it
yeah to lean in yeah yeah um well now
you're in the final season of this is us
so what's going on with your character
rebecca oh way to bring it down um
so we're tying up
you know over 100 episodes of this show
and telling the story of this family and
my character
uh present day obviously i play this
woman from 25 to 85 and present day
she's dealing with dementia with
alzheimer's so it's it's quite
heartbreaking but i love that we're able
to have this conversation and hopefully
destigmatize the conversation around
alzheimer's and um including the family
and all of the the decisions that like
everyone as a unit collectively has to
make together
um but it's
i'm so excited that we get to sort of
wrap up this story and in a really
beautiful way and i think people are
going to be
happy with us the way we stick the
landing as it were yeah is it i have a
question because is it hard to snap out
of that when you leave work because
y'all do cover so many serious
situations and scenarios within family
dynamics is that hard to like
compartmentalize when you go home i
think like for me especially in this
particular situation like i grieve for
my character my character is very
intentional she's very stoic she has so
much grace the way she's sort of
handling this diagnosis
and i as mandy have to not let my
feelings for her my sadness my grief
like kind of bleed into the performance
so it's like i'll sometimes leave set
and get back you know to my trailer in
my car and just like
ugh like
it's an emotional release but
also like there's so much levity in
between takes everybody's so funny on
the show like we do find ways to sort of
like crack jokes in between because
otherwise it would be a horrible workout
everybody's just like exactly just
crying all the time so yeah we have to
find a way to like liven it up yeah i
love your cast we've had almost
everybody on here it's the most
remarkable group of people i feel so
lucky that i've been like spent the last
six years of my life with them i love
them so deeply that's awesome the best
um well what has it meant to you um that
you've shown so much diversity on the
show especially within a family
yeah like the family dynamics but what a
family can look like i mean i'm so
grateful again that we've had the
opportunity that people have been
interested in the show from the very
beginning and have kind of come along on
this this journey with us for the last
six years like i think it's the
conversations we've been able to elicit
are so important yeah it's been the
greatest gift to be a part of something
that's so cathartic and emotional and
also reflective of even though there's
so much specificity in who these people
are in these different stories like
people are still able to see themselves
in it and oh yeah such a gift yeah that
is a gift be a part of something that
means yeah that means something to
people yeah
so everybody is sad that this is us is
coming to an end so are you feeling kind
of bittersweet about it like it's a
great cast but are you excited about
doing new things i mean you know look
i'll be honest for me i mean i don't
really work with anybody but mandy
because i'm you know deceased in the
present day it's like i never work with
the kids they have everyone right
no no
oh so the thing is like they'll be on
set like wherever we are and like
they'll just kind of group together an
inside joke inside joke and i'm lost
dead dad i have no idea what's going on
i'm lost dead dad but like for for me
for me it's like yes it is it is a
little bitter sweet to like leave the
group but for me it's like it's the crew
it's always the crew i mean you spend
day after day with you know the people
that you're with all the time you see
them you walk past them yeah you know
their kids names you know everything
about them yeah and then it's just kind
of done yeah it is move on it is true
though like i i still see the crew from
like 20 years ago when i won american
idol i still know the crew and i run
into them like awards and stuff it's so
crazy because we've all grown up
together like 20 years and those are the
people that you see and you'll still see
on different productions yep absolutely
yeah that is that is true um well
someone told me that you have a set
photographer who's very passionate about
getting the best angle which first of
all god bless you sir angles are
important um but i want to see that
because let's see some photographer ron
i feel like he took y'all he took
pictures oh yeah so this is and now you
all started taking pictures so this is
ron battsdorf how it all started was
there was a scene where i'm standing in
front of one of my children's desks and
i'm looking at something on the desk and
i have james over here with his camera
and i have coy over here with his camera
and the only place for ron to get a
decent photo was to wedge himself behind
the desk and shoot up at me and i'm like
ron you realize you're in my eye line
i'm looking right at this this book this
frame and he's like i need to get the
shot oh my god and i was like okay man
so i took some photos of him and it
became a joke a joke and a gag where
whenever ron would be in just a funny
position i would take a photo then i
started an instagram account then the
entire crew started contributing to it
yeah so i mean i would take photos but
then you know somebody else would take a
photo just and they would send them to
me like oh my god you should have seen
where ron was today he's on the kitchen
counter oh my god he should have seen
where ron was the other day like he's
outside under a ladder under yeah i love
it that's koi that's ron
yeah
ear pointing
well that's and that's the thing like he
always like dresses in black to blend in
with a dark set a dark stage unless
we're filming at a pharmacy then he's
wearing all white because a pharmacy oh
god i mean this so this one right here
logan shoyer it's a big scene uh i think
season three where where kevin breaks
his knee and his football days are over
and i've got this massive speech where
i'm talking to kevin telling him like
he's gonna find his true calling and i
see ron just creeping out from behind
what you're trying to be like and i'm
like ron i'm like you gotta leave man
you are killing my vibe you really are
yeah well that's another thing i'm never
doing that i'm usually just like singing
but oh yeah what that's creepy so so
that was reflections so again you know
ron would dress in dark clothes because
he never wants to reflect or something
in a surface so this was he couldn't
reflect in wherever we were so he just
shrouded himself entirely i got so many
photos that day that one was i think
taken by crickey or sound sound board
operator everybody though that day sent
me a photo of ron in a black cape just
if ron were really funny he would have
had someone else just sit there and then
just walk up with another camera like
like who's the guy under the chair i
mean i have photos of just his camera
sitting on tables like on the instagram
account too it's just like ron where
like literally where are you on auto
he's like i was busy there we go and
here's your gentleman yeah there's weiss
get it wife yes wife has actually been
that's what i'm saying has been around
me for i don't know 15 i don't know how
many years we're working together but on
tour i don't even notice weiss is there
like there have been times
things have happened and i have no idea
why i'm like well so let's talk this is
us like how are you feeling is it
bittersweet because this is such a
brilliant cast the chemistry is done so
well ever it's such a popular show and
it's just such a great message to the
family vibe from the show it's just been
so great overall so is it kind of
bittersweet for you excited to do other
things but you're also like kind of sad
that's exactly what it is um i love the
show yeah it's been one of the best
six-year ride of my life yeah like
professionally it's been absolutely
amazing beautiful people i'm looking at
my black pearson family over here
and i've gotten a chance to see these
three little girls grow up over time
like every time i'm on stage with them
i'm like i'm going to miss them and i
see their parents who are backstage with
and i was like i love your dogs and
you've watched them grow up and i've
literally watched them grow up so once
we start to get to like the last two or
three episodes
there'll be something that happens that
i won't be able to stop from happening
oh no because i know i'm actually saying
goodbye right now i'm like oh we're
having a great time and just blah blah
blah when it gets to the end oh no
there'll be no acting it'll be ugly
crazy it'll be ugly okay hideous yeah
that's great though yeah so it's crazy
this is the the final season this is it
oh nuts are you super emotional about it
because not many shows are lucky enough
to get this kind of i mean it's such a
huge epic like pop culture moment this
show
like to be a part of something like that
is massive so is it kind of so sad like
you're literally getting me two days
after we just wrapped so it's like
i'm like oh that's hard you're like are
you okay all right okay do you need a
hug i think so
that's so weird because you've seen
these people every day for yeah for six
years and it really is like a ripping
away of like people who have become
your family you know in so many ways and
so it was very surreal but like the one
thing i told myself that i'm gonna do
is
every day for like the past last month
of it i was like just be present and
just take it in because then at least i
can say i remember i was there i was i
didn't like leave my body and like try
to push it out of my mind it's not
happening whatever it was like you know
it's happening let it be the long
goodbye and just like experience it and
i thought maybe then i wouldn't cry
and it did not work
i was like and then
yeah and then i cried um well i saw this
video um it's the whole cast and it went
viral so i want to show everybody this
so so what was going on here this was
impromptu look at sir
um this was like us on a break so we had
like all this time uh we this is like a
18-hour day
and um we were there from like six
o'clock look at the booties um look at
the bodies we were there from like uh i
think i got there eight o'clock in the
morning i remember leaving just after
midnight but like we were all there and
we were shooting the um
kate second wedding to phil
and um a wonderful person who runs our
social uh sarah werheim came in she
always has ideas for us to do and she
was coming to sterling with something
and i think between her and sterling
they came up with this idea and he was
asking me about music choices and i was
like oh you should do something that
people would play at a barbecue
everybody can dance yeah and he came up
with the wobble and then he taught
everybody yeah and um you know except
for mr hartley he's just chilling on no
well see he knows his position he knows
like you know
he's like i know my lane i'm going to be
here
does he not dance is this what it is no
ma'am he just no ma'am
listen does he not do it well did he not
do it he did it well i love it he's just
on the phone yeah yeah he was like he's
making deals
yeah i was like that just means he don't
dance
and that's what we do on our break that
was like a break and um and we were you
know
it's a way to like just kind of get
through
um so congrats it was announced that you
are actually co-writing one of the
episodes for this is us this season
that's exciting yeah it was honestly
like i mean you're a writer like a
songwriter so it's kind of like the same
way yeah outsourcing i mean there's a
melody yeah it's story there's a melody
of sorts it's not necessarily you know
well we we just finished it oh okay and
i got the network network draft and i
was like wait some of the things that i
wrote are in the draft oh
like i didn't think it was going to
happen because there's so many rewrites
there's so many different influences and
voices and of course the whole writers
room who have been writing for millions
of years and yeah like oh you're an
actor you want to write and i'm like
yeah please let me try and so a lot of
my my jokes
landed and stuck and so i'm really
excited and it's the kate centric
episode yeah so it's out of the trilogy
it kind of made sense yeah that you were
yeah that made sense yeah you're very
smart
yeah and so i'm really excited about it
it's something i always wanted to do so
are you interested in any other like
behind-the-scenes stuff would you ever
want to like direct or produce or do
anything like that you know produce yes
direct eventually i feel like i really
want to know like
everything before i'm like let me be the
boss
of everybody um in a nice way but um
yeah eventually i'm so different i'm
like i never want to do anything else
i'm just like i'm not just one thing
when you're really good at it you don't
really have no no you're really gonna
where you i just mean like it just seems
like a lot those people
to wear all those hats seems like a lot
it's a lot of pressure and i'm like
really like bare minimum like
i don't know if you're bare minimum yeah
i'm bare minimum level
is there what oh my god especially
towards the end of the year it's so
great um cheers
still even wines over here um
no but can you tell us anything about
the final season everybody this show is
such a huge show people are just yeah
they're probably very sad but it's not
very sad i know it's not weird that
you've been around people for that long
and then all of a sudden you're not
going to see them every day i don't mean
to make you cry yeah about it you know
i'm an emotional i am too like she's
really trying to weld these up no no no
no it's honestly every day everyone's
like chrissy you okay i'm like don't ask
me if i'm okay are we all okay yeah um
yeah it's emotional
you spend six years of your life with
people who've changed your life and
stories that have changed other people's
lives so yeah i'm emotional but also
this
this season is going to be incredible
and you know i don't know if anybody has
seen the finale of season five yes okay
some people have if you haven't close
your ears
spoiler alert
we will get to see how toby and kate
sort of
unravel okay um and then of course we're
following um rebecca's storyline and her
alzheimer's and yeah um
it's going to be very emotional and and
very wonderful and beautiful and you
know seems nice to have wine with as
well
that's right how are you i'm doing great
nice to meet you great to meet you yeah
we're very excited to have you so you've
had a great run on this as us it's such
a great show so many people it's
impacted um just pop culture in such a
big way but this show is coming to an
end this year so that's that's kind of a
big thing especially for a cast that
you've kind of grown with over the years
um i don't know i heard you almost
didn't even audition yeah i had like
four auditions that week and i had a
dentist appointment that conflicted with
the audition oh my god
i had school and my mom like really
really wanted me to go to this dentist
appointment so we were trying to move
the audition and then i was like no i
just i just got to go and do this and
and then like the next day i booked it
the next morning i was on the show and
it just like rolled from there it was
like pretty insane it's always crazy
like that it always happens crazy like
that i feel like when people tell me
about their big first things
well what can we expect from the final
season
i can't really tell you anything get out
i'm just kidding
yeah i'm just kidding i know no spoiler
alerts we don't want you to spoil it
but like let's just say it wraps up in a
very i mean it wraps up in a very like
specific way and just
i'm gonna need tissues oh i love crying
it's gonna be yeah be prepared yeah okay
okay i love a good cry
[Music]
you